audrey joins us now from burmanzee with
the latest uh sadio on this uh story
that suggests uh all parties involved
knew each other beforehand
yes that's what police have told us that
the four people who died here and the
man who is currently in custody uh
we believe are known to each other
um the incident happened here on
delaford road in burmanzi it's a very
quiet area
on a normal day but today there is a lot
of police activity you can see the
coordinates set up behind me there's a
screen and just behind that our aerial
shots have shown that there are four
forensic tents that were in place this
morning
forensics teams are coming and going
and still there are there is according
in place and there are police vehicles
around here there's a lot of activity
from the neighbors as well who are you
know
standing around on a corner here meeting
each other comforting each other this is
something that has really shocked this
neighborhood it happened
just uh
in the early hours of this morning at
around 140 emergency services responded
to what they were told was a disturbance
at a property here they came when they
arrived they had to force their way into
a a property and they found four people
there who had fatal stab injuries
ambulance services did attend uh but
were unable to save them and uh next of
kin are being uh
informed and the police say that there
is a process on going to arrange
post-mortems to establish the exact
cause of death and we spoke to some of
the neighbors here who talked about how
shocked they were one gentleman told us
that he'd heard screaming just before
the police arrived the local mp for
campbell and pekkam is harriet harman
she also paid a visit to the scene and
spoke to some of the police officers and
we grabbed a quick
interview with her have a listen to what
she had to say
well this is a very quiet settled
peaceful lovely neighborhood and
everybody is absolutely shocked nobody
expects this to happen anywhere but let
alone in a neighborhood like this and
obviously
we're grateful to the police that
they've arrested somebody already but
it's important for anybody who's got any
information at all to come forward with
that information
whoever's done this must be brought to
justice for this horrific set of
killings we've seen you just come over
and speak to the police officers what
have they said to you
well you know they they like me know
it's it's a quiet neighborhood and
everybody is really shocked but
obviously the forensics is being done um
in the house
and we hope that they can conclude the
investigations as quickly as possible
and everybody's just
really thoughts are with the relatives
and friends of those people who've been
killed in what is such a peaceful and
nice community here
well among the tributes that have come
in today uh the london mayor sadiq khan
also tweeted he he wrote i am
heartbroken that there are three women
and a man
were killed last night in a devastating
incident at an address in southwark my
thoughts are with the family and friends
who have lost loved ones in this awful
crime well as i say police are
continuing to investigate they are in
the process of contacting the next of
kin of the four people who have died
here and they have arrested one man on
suspicion of murder he remains in
custody at a police station in south
london